[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have amber very famous she's a
kpop star she's in a girl group called
FX she also does her own stuff and she
has a YouTube channel and she's a llama
as she runs para races yeah and I also
am on Jackie party a lot she is you know
what's crazy for the longest time I
thought you're just like Cory just kpop
huh they were I think they were trying
to start going to the Chinese market at
the time because hyung hyung who was in
Super Junior was also he's also Chinese
member yeah that was in the group but
yeah like so everybody was like going
toward like Japan China that all the
other like Asian major markets at that
time so when I was brought in how long
ago that this like branching out star
this was I think it started because kpop
was getting really big in other parts of
Asia yeah so I think it started around
like early 2000s okay so then I think
that's when they started actually
scouting outside of Korea and so like
you know America like I think it's some
of Europe as well um Southeast Asia and
that's how you got recruited yeah cuz
like when I was in the company there was
like there couple Japanese kids there
was a lot of Chinese kids a lot of
Americans a lot of Malaysian there's
like uh it was like a variety so I could
think there wasn't like a specific goal
at that time I just like let's just try
to like diversify everything I've never
seen a dark k-pop star
there's actually a couple black artists
right now in in Korea that's singing
Korean that are actually really
phenomenal that's other k-pop yeah k-pop
and they're actually enjoyed this
speaking Korean speaking Korean yes
they're actually really there a few
better than me
wait so how'd you get scouted they kind
of I was actually just out uh you know
that there's like cream festival that
happens like every year in in k-town I
was just standing in the crowd yeah
they're like you I'm gonna make you a
I was like okay literally so what are
you like dancing or so no I walk I was I
was I was your there oh wow I was really
like those stories really happened was
you have a started based off of my looks
your bone structure
I knew my label but it was just like me
really but apparently I was scouted by a
mr. SM himself who's this he's like he's
like the chairman of the label he was
eating a popsicle or something at the
k-town fair oh you somebody's like the
la Reed of Korea kind of pretty much so
like yeah he scouted me I'm told he said
lady mmm he's eating something about her
he's eating him in the turtle pops yeah
ninja turtle popsicle gumballs
no push the [ __ ] ice that girl right
there go get her go in what's that like
um well I had the his employee came and
get came and got me and I didn't find
that out until later but I think I was
the way that I was hearing from multiple
people was that I was scouted because in
China there was I forgot her name but
there was a a like tomboyish type of
singer in China she was huge so he kind
of wanted to emulate that in Korea as
well how did you know that you were
talented you didn't give a [ __ ] it's
like I could build anybody he's like she
looks like agent Peter Pan it's perfect
exactly but like cool cuz everything is
like kind of like they're trainable you
know like honestly good thing yeah
honest I didn't I thought that like you
know like you have to be born a singer
born a dancer but to be really honest
like other than like though they're like
you know touchy things like you know you
have to have like a sense of music and
like rhythm and stuff like have you seen
Julia have you seen Julia dance or try
to like I think that could be drink
something some people need more training
than others like it's like honestly like
if you work really hard at it if you
like really focus on your craft you can
like work hard too you won't you won't
Beyonce does though
but you started training when she was
like five or six but anybody can there
haven't you seen those movies where
actors sing and [ __ ] and you're like wow
they actually did a pretty good job cuz
they got trained except for Russell
Crowe in [ __ ] lame is Rob that was
[ __ ] garbage so is that not common
knowledge only because I grew up with my
parent their musician yeah so I to me I
see it as like okay you learn to play
basketball you learn to jump rope like
it's all just a skill is that not a
common I think there's a there's a
divide between skill in genius though
like people got I believe you can learn
to have a skill like I can learn to draw
but then what separates an actual like a
professional painter slash artist or
fall of life is abloom is they're like
you know at the very top everyone's
talented yeah there's everyone's
talented at the top but what separates
the best from them it's work ethic it's
work ethic and vision as well right
because like you have like I think
especially now nowadays like back then
like music industry was still like
everywhere was like a baby so like you
had Pete like Michael Jackson you had
like Bobby Brown and like everybody just
like creating the industry right now
everybody's talented everybody has skill
the kids that are debuting now dude
they're [ __ ] insane they all dance
what they all sing well yeah you have to
know it's like a for sure you guys
thought I'm now boot camp let's do it
just do it over to Korea kpop boot boot
camp how long did you train I trained
for a year and a half so I buy my period
of training was actually very short
compared to others it's Korean training
right it's not lazy American training I
know in Asia it's like probably like
eight 12-hour days so like in America oh
I want to be a senior I sing I go to
class once a week but then like Asian
style tight you better be sleep singing
until you're [ __ ] bleeding from the
throat and again tomorrow and again
and again pro-american style of a go
pretty hardcore
oh yeah like the like that you know that
the drummer movie like for the foreign
artists that don't speak Korean that we
would have Korean class in the morning
show up at the facility at like we want
one or two and then like do training
every day was pretty much different just
because like some classes would happen
on Wednesday some classes what happened
on this so when you're learning Korean
and then like you're going to these
things they they speak in Korean right
yeah so you're like learning as you're
going and then they're like time to time
that attended and then you're like what
the [ __ ] is happening in and they're
like getting it back pretty much cuz
like well I had a there was this one
dance class that it would only happen at
like 3 p.m. and I was at that time I was
the only person taking that class so the
teacher would be trying to teach me in
Korean like it was a dance so she'd be
all like huh I was like but dancing so
visual but you have to like understand
that with dancing it's emotion it's like
dad said that like or like five and six
and seven eight like you want to be
angry with the hand but first like two
months I was completely confused but I
was like you know nodding my head and
like I know what this yeah sure why not
that's tight but uh yeah I was pretty
much it before you got discovered did
you sing and dance I really did like
church stuff but other than that like I
only choreography I knew was from tech
window but I'm not like everything's
pretty like again I think everything's
trainable is just to get to that next
level and then to exceed is like if you
are passionate for it and what your
vision for it now you're in there right
and they just introduced you to want to
be like this is your Co bandmates
I'm not sure about other companies but
our company we three my members were
actually already in like this kind of
group we debuted us five we're at four
right now but three of them were
actually already in a group and are the
member was already gonna debut as an
actress model or whatever and then I
came in I was like the latest one to
come in but I think within like six
months before we debuted they're all
like we have these like weekly tests and
then I'm also like
like I think like a big test every three
months with like the actual execs like a
screen test yeah pretty like American
Idol but then like not televised yeah
pretty much so the weekly test were like
that and then like the 3-month tests
were like this huge showcase pretty much
and then you have a huge Erwin every six
months so that's when like the execs
actually evaluate and do all this stuff
and yeah it factor or like they start
like kind of like like putting people
together and then like okay I guess for
the next three months put these five
people together and see how they work
together that kind of stuff so like
being put in a group that already is a
group and then you're the new person it
was kind of weird efforts but luckily I
was already close to my members before
yeah
cuz we all train together so you have
although you're like little classes and
then like when you get thrown into a
group together you're just kind of like
huh so it's like it's like high school
boot camp yeah pretty much like oh [ __ ]
from other class so you already know
each other it's not stranger and plus
like um one of my members Crystal's she
she she speaks English she's from the
she's from the bay I think or somewhere
in San Francisco so I spent a lot of my
time with her because she would get off
school and then she would like come and
she'd be like what are you doing and I'm
like I don't know what I'm doing what
does this mean she's like that and then
my other member was Chinese so we would
speak Chinese a lot together so we were
kind of already like we're already kind
of close and then I lived with my other
members well so it's like you know it
was like great it was actually pretty
good it was just like the whole
communication factor was hard because we
speaking three languages at once
yeah and then you know just very
different cultures so a lot of
communication was very much needed in
the beginning of our group just because
of language barrier but then I think
that brought us closer together but it's
fascinating cuz you're you're you're
under contract so it's like you wake up
one day you just said you're five
members and then he said you have four
members you just wake up one day and the
members like gone um so she just had
other artistic like ambitions and you
know we were just like you know if
that's what makes you happy go ahead oh
so she chose to leave yeah she chose to
leave I don't like I know there's a lot
of drama with like other groups that
have my people leaving and like oh my
gosh then they call them out on Twitter
whatever social media platform but
ours was just very like if you don't
want to do it it's totally fine you know
do your thing and I think she know she's
going through stuff so like you know
it's like you know who's not going
through that and I think our group was
very like you know just not I don't say
it wasn't chill it was just like you
know we understand so cuz you know it's
like the worst part about like kpop is
that in the end a lot of the groups are
just very manufactured and we are being
we're like building different people
being put into one group and we just
spend 24 hours with each other you're
gonna go crazy
eventually yeah because it wasn't
naturally like fit yeah so but luckily
there are groups that like do stick
together yeah for four years
backstreet's back
oh but you know Indiana it was just kind
of like we all get it and it's just like
if you're not happy doing something as a
friend we don't want to hold you back
from your happiness that's all American
have you have you ever seen somebody get
kicked out oh yeah
it's like you're not boy bandy enough
for like that kind of thing do they get
kicked out cuz you're like you're not
good enough to be really honest I feel
really bad for people the person I
technically kind of replaced
cuz there were people the the group girl
trainees that were training with me at
the time a lot of them already trained
for like three to five six years and you
had this whole play somebody I know just
take a plea yeah yeah kind of I don't
good you see her lead crying holding a
little plant and stuff box with the
stapler now was that stapler she cleared
like basically cuz our group FX was
basically made with girls that train
less than five years and most girls
trained for like like six of it and they
still sucked and they were actually
really talented and that's what I felt
even worse because when you go into the
company these are the girls that take
care of you because they've been you
there for so long veteran and
so like when our group got put together
it's just like what like you know like
the hierarchy in Korean culture it's
like why is my jr. like in this group
okay it doesn't kind of hurts but Leah
they were all really nice girls yeah but
I actually still keep in touch with a
couple of them and it was just like I
was just like are you happy they're like
yeah I'm actually really happy like
doing my own thing
there's a girl in red velvet who is
actually a junior group of ours that
debuted I think like a couple at least
three four years after us yeah
and her name is Sookie she's actually my
trainee senior like she's she's younger
than me but she actually was in the
company before me oh wow I was like I
was like yeah yes every time like I
would go back to the like the company
like before she debuted I'd be like when
you debut and man I want to see you
onstage and then like she's like I don't
know yet but you know she was there for
seven years seven eight years I was like
oh but she's she's super talented she's
killing it right now and like you know
what about the chick that you replaced
were you like when do you Devi on time
just kidding a lot of them are actually
pretty like they're actually kind of
happy that they like like kind of left
cuz like you know you're just in the
company for a long time not knowing
what's gonna happen and you don't know
when you're gonna do just a good talent
incubator right like you just don't know
what's gonna you never know when you're
gonna debut so we're all competing to
debut and it's just like you know Dean
also it's just a talent Factory up until
the time that they decide to release you
yes in very very bold terms yes has
anyone tried to sabotage you no no
actually no oh I would imagine like some
pageant girl drama stuff they throw
marbles in like while they're trying to
dance don't break your ankle typical
like like high school drama that kind of
stuff but like you can't like not really
any sabotage you can just no one put
glue in your shampoos no one put X locks
in your coffee or anything I don't know
when this go air but let's just say like
not the trainees but other people in the
company and definitely try to sabotage
me but but luckily I did do it and they
they're they're not in the picture
anymore were they trying to sabotage
what does that mean they put kimchi in
her [ __ ] coffee maybe basically
like you know slip something to the
existing volleyball blah Oh
I'd be in people's ear like the the guy
that like I knew pushed for me like
crazy was the main choreographer god
that's eating the popsicle in k-town
yeah he's them he's the boss of the body
he owns the company I'm a choreographer
like he still says to this day like you
know keep doing whatever the [ __ ] makes
you happy because he knows that like I'm
just very driven like to do my [ __ ]
that's time and he was he was I was like
thank you for like I knew you're the guy
that pushed me to debut oh he's like you
do whatever the [ __ ] makes you happy
while wearing all white and having
swoopy here exactly
pretty much pretty much that before you
were discovered what did you want to do
was it wasn't I wanted to do bio
engineering or like environmental
science and stuff that's the devil in
that I how do you dabble in that it's so
complicated my mental capacity will not
let me learn more about that stuff but
like I still like I do you kind of also
need a lab yeah subjects you know my
weekend gig is that I we're gonna
nuclear power plant I thought of
immediately we should said that I
thought of bows cuz she reads statistics
for fun so that's not like oh do you
download it so I try at least like with
my job I think the only way that I can
help my other goal is to like maybe get
enough money to fund these cool projects
that like are coming out with like more
energy friendly stuff or you know
environmental cleanups and I would try
to like I would search up they find a
time to like go to an actual trash
cleanup cuz I want to get my hands or I
don't wanna just give like give money it
would be amazing to but I don't have
that money yet so I just want to like be
more involved in the actual local like
cleanups and like you know just do more
charity work in that sense but I my
sister is really big in you know
nonprofit and stuff like that so I would
try to like educate myself as much as I
can by also just what kind of nonprofit
does she do does she take out the
plastic in the ocean yes okay
she does she did a lot of a lot of like
we called women's rights stuff and know
that like more like social stuff I don't
remember my sister's a veterinarian and
so she had to animal rights part of her
will partly animal rights college credit
knowledge it was she had to volunteer at
this like facility for sheltered animals
or some [ __ ]
San Diego Zoo yeah she no it's something
like that but it was like you know in
the mountains and I had to go with her
and like you know you get that thing in
your heart we're like his [ __ ]
charity dollars [ __ ] and then I might
clean up
owl [ __ ] and all the stuff and I'm like
[ __ ] this I'm never doing this [ __ ]
again
me a bar volunteered at a hospital and I
helped the grandma take a [ __ ] and I
said [ __ ] this it's not for me
yeah how do you help a grandma take a
[ __ ] holding your shoulders no like me
and the the LVN that not the nurse nurse
but whatever like we all had to like the
reforms although move her yeah move her
to the side so she could pull out the
bedpan and clean that and all that and
I'm just like I was just like [ __ ] there
are chair like if that's not for you I
think you would be great at like there's
this thing that people in Korea do where
you deliver coal to places that don't
have heaters and I do that every year as
much as I can
coal coal like things like you got a big
hole Rock the briquettes I think that
briquettes so like you we delivered
those things and then it's just heavy
[ __ ] and it's like labor is like you
have your not power trip over them like
if I had a backpack full of coal in this
geyser
oh thank god you're here like oh really
do you want cuz they're actually really
nice to you too do you look in the eyes
as you turn on the heater and you're
like are you really thankful there if
you're not there most of the time so you
just basically just go to this thing and
I just buy electric stove with a solar
charger and then I bring that over well
there's a lot of places that don't have
like electricity and that son Joe I just
gave it it's Korea I this thing when I'm
cleaning up al [ __ ] it's not rewarding
because the al doesn't say thank you but
when it turns its head like 270 degrees
how much did it say say [ __ ] but it's
sick let's see in your position you get
no reward for the [ __ ] where's your
feedback I
work if I had to be very just like if I
need to get something out of it I get a
workout out of it because my next day my
legs look amazing but if you had a cold
person hugging you or something that's I
think that's nothing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]